Глина – це така річ, вона не всім дається в руки.
Це має бути якась... Ну, не талант, можливо,
але хоча би якась схильність.
Кажуть, що гори обирають людей, які будуть їх прославляти.
Кераміка справді прославила гори.
Це наша майстеренька,
де фактично робиться вся гончарна справа.
Тобто створюється форма.
Від того, що я замішую глину, робота гончаря за кругом.
Тут все зроблено для того, щоб суто зробити, підсушити.
І два етапи, в косівській кераміці, проходять тут.
Треба трішки глину, перед тим
як поставити її на круг, пробудити зі сну.
Розім'яти її трішечки.
До цього я був військовим.
В один прекрасний момент,
якось так склалося, що почав займатися гончарством.
Пішов до одного з гончарів тут місцевих, точніше, до двох.
Зрозумів, що я можу це робити,
і так воно все пішло, пішло, пішло.
Ось така у нас вийшла салатничка.
Вже наступний етап – це вже малювання,
знову просушка, перший випал.
Нанесення фарби, поливи, другий випал
і лиш тоді  – кінцевий результат.
Це все дуже довго триває.
Ми зараз легенько намічаємо малюнок.
Тобто, у нас уже в руках виріб, який,
от бачите, з червоної глини зроблений.
Тобто – основа плитки.
І покритий білою глиною.
Він вже зараз придатний до того, щоб малювати.
Особливість цієї кераміки – ми малюнок прорізаємо.
Тобто, це щось схоже до різьблення по дереву,
хоча матеріал не такий твердий.
Але ми вирізаємо через цей білий шар глини.
Ми прорізаємо малюнок до тіла,
до червоної глини.
І оце, ви бачите,
ми маємо оцей коричневий контур.
Сама ця техніка, вона називається «сграфіто».
І перші роботи, які були зроблені в цій техніці,
були зроблені в Ірані в ІХ столітті.
Там просто надзвичайно красиві роботи,
які дуже схожі до того,
що робили гуцули у XVIII столітті.
Технологія завжди була та сама, але люди малювали...
Ну, відрізнялися малюнки.
Тобто люди малювали те, що вони бачили,
вони малювали свою культуру.
Те, що було для них звично.
Коли у нас питають: «А ви павичів намалювати можете?».
Можемо, але ми не малюємо.
Ми гуцули, у гуцулів не було павичів.
От баранця чого малювали?
Це було молоко, шерсть,
це було м'ясо, це було гарно.
Останні 200 років вважалося, що косівська кераміка –
вона виключно тут зародилася,
і вона лише для цього регіону характерна.
Але явно вона тут не зародилася.
Хтось просто сюди завіз
цю технологію виготовлення цієї кераміки.
У світі вона була, просто Косів залишився
тим осередком, де вона збереглася.
Те що я малюю, наприклад, —
це не є традиційна косівська кераміка в повному сенсі.
Я взагалі починала з того,
що я поєднувала гуцульські елементи
зі скандинавськими переплетеннями,
з кельтськими переплетеннями.
Тобто те, що мене найбільше захоплювало.
Потім почала додавати туди
і якісь візантійські елементи, і так далі.
Тобто мені от цікаво поєднати,
через орнамент, різні культури.
Це я напускаю зараз червеню.
Оцей колір, це йде в мене в груші – це йде глина.
Потім на кераміці воно дає коричневий колір.
Тобто, зараз у нас задіяні три глини.
Ось ця темна.
Ось цей фон.
І оця третя глина — йде коричневий колір.
Тобто тут уже три глини у нас присутні.
Коли воно випалюється
після першого разу, колір робиться...
Оце повністю біле буде,
і ззаду як цеглинка, червоний такий колір.
Тоді вже напускається фарбами,
але кожен майстер робить цю фарбу сам.
Тобто ніколи немає... І от це єдина,
до речі, фарба, яку не можна купити.
От зараз є безліч фарб, безліч текстур, фактур,
тобто, як то кажуть, до кольору – до вибору.
Але, власне, цієї гуцульської нашої, прозорої, зеленої,
і з отим відтінком, яким тобі потрібно, – її ніколи немає.
Навіть майстрів впізнають по почерку, по кольору.
Тобто у нас уже знають:  світліший колір —
це той майстер, темніший колір — той майстер.
І кожен раз треба вміти зробити свій колір.
Після першого випалу, я пензликом
напускаю всі — де жовте, де зелене.
Воно ще потім стоїть підсихає,
а потім іде полива зверху.
Заливається поливою, і другий випал.
Це наша пічечка.
Цілий!
Так провіряється кераміка.
Якби вона була тріснута,
вона б мала вже глухий звук такий.
Зараз ми вже на наступному етапі
будемо наносити жовтий і зелений кольори.
Два кольори.
І покривати це поливою, то що блистить,
власне, це немов склом покриваємо.
І знову в піч.
І тоді вона вже буде готова,
ось так як тут, бачте.
Зелений додасться, жовтий.
Ці розводи якраз роблять цю кераміку неповторною.
Малюнок ще складно повторити, а це взагалі...
Це – природа випалу,
ми на це ніякого впливу не маємо.
Я не знаю, де воно потече.
Ви наносите все однаково, однаково наносите фарбу.
В одному місці воно потече, а в другому — ні.
Це так мов людина має родинки на собі.
У кожного вони є,
але в кожного десь в інших місцях.
Так само і це: ця кераміка, власне,
цим і відрізняється від усієї іншої.
Що ця одна робота буде зроблена лише для одної людини.
Хочемо ми того, чи не хочемо.
Я не наважуся на жодних учнів,
тому що я сама нічого, мені здається, ще не знаю.
20 років, але щоразу, під час кожного випалу,
у нас переживання.
Доти воно виходить.
По цей день я ще вчуся, щось роблю,
щось піддивляюся, щось думаю.
Хоча, насправді, там вже нема що видумувати,
все давно видумано до нас.
Ми тільки повторюємо, як виявляється,
якісь речі, та і все.
Щось говорить через покоління, можна так сказати.